well of course the Conservatives are
enjoying their 80 seat majority it was a
tricky election night for the Liberal
Democratic Party choice Winston began
the campaign sitting opposite me in this
very studio claiming that she was a
realistic candidate for Prime Minister
on Thursday night she lost her seat and
so just 11 MPs returned for her party
well that means the Lib Dems are left
with one less MP than we had after the
2017 election and 10 less than at the
start of the campaign because all of the
people that had defected from other
parties failed to win their seats well
joining us now to discuss where they go
next is the party's joint acting leader
said Davey thank you very much good
morning on a programme let's address the
elephant in the room first there's a
vacancy at the top of your party are you
planning on running for the leadership
again as we just had a very tough
election I'm delighted to have won my
seat but I'm talking to colleagues
who've had some really tough times and
lost their seat what we're going to do
is as Acting leader I'm going to ensure
that we review the general election
properly learn those lessons and make
sure we're fit to oppose this Boris
Johnson government as we is in our job
to do so that's the role I'll be
focusing in on in my role as Acting
leader and can you give us a bit of a
idea of a time frame for this when is
the leadership election likely to take
place well the board of the party is
going to meet in January and is going to
set the timetable for the leadership
election as acting leader our bill
should be supporting the board but
focusing in on talking to our members
clearly not just our party's members but
supporters and many people who want a
progressive centre party are deeply
disappointed at the moment and I think
is vital they see politicians omitting
where mistakes are made but also
standing up to this quite nationalistic
right-wing conservative government
that's been elected to just be crystal
clear you're not ruling yourself in or
out it's too early for that we've got to
focus on ensuring we learn the lessons
properly in a quite a deep profound way
I mean one of the lessons I have to say
is it can be very difficult for the
Democrats to make progress when there is
a hard left leader they party
1983 with Michael foot we found in
spades in 29 with Jeremy Corbyn if you
look at the conservative leaflets in
libel Democrat consensus it wasn't so
much get brexit done they were talking
about they were saying if you vote
little democrat you'll catch enemy
Corbin and that fear factor was a
massive issue in the general ledger at
the same time though many people would
look at this and think this is a perfect
opportunity for a party the center
ground to come through when many people
feel Boris Johnson is a right-wing Prime
Minister and then you have an unpopular
leader on the left wing
surely this gives you space in the
center ground that you've failed to
grasp well we clearly fail to grasp it
and we need to learn the lessons of why
but I'm pointing out to you that there
were a lot of liberal conservatives who
read don't like brexit don't like Boris
Johnson but they actually fear Jeremy
Corbyn even more and you don't have to
believe me look at the leaflets that the
Conservative Party were putting out in
the key seats we were trying to win and
they played on that fear factor of
Jeremy Corbyn and what I hope is that we
can see Labour Party reform because we
do need to work cross-party we need to
cooperate we try that very much in the
last Parliament as we try to get a
people's vote we didn't quite get the
full cooperation that we needed we try
that at this this election we were
working with in the Green Party Pleiku
Murray we try to work across across
party boundaries but in the
first-past-the-post with a very hard
left and popper Leader the Labour Party
it proved very very difficult now when
you're on the show before the election I
asked what you would have done
differently to Joe Swinson if you've
been elected leader you just have a
quick look at what you told me and
before this you said that you had done
nothing differently I think she's been
doing a fantastic job
I think her leadership on brexit has
been inspiring what would you actually
have done differently well I would
certainly have done exactly what Joe did
on the BEC see question we are a
pro-european party you believe Britain
should remain in the EU and I'm very
proud that Joe let a party where she
made that a central position I think the
question is more about what you'd have
done differently not the same well as
acting lead
I want to work out what went wrong and
what kind of work and well let's let us
look at this in detail I was at the
board meeting yesterday in Liberal HQ
where we have set up a general election
review we'll look at all the details we
won't no stone will be left unturned
clearly we can bust of make mistakes we
wouldn't have had the result that we did
but all I'm saying is judging from what
I've already heard from members and from
candidates and from party activists the
Conservative Party beat us in many seats
were you expecting to win because they
played on the fear of Jeremy Corbyn that
that's just a fact
they'll be fed into the review will also
have to own up to the mistakes that we
made I'm not denying that what are they
because it does feel a little bit like
you know you're blaming Jeremy Corbyn
you say you would have done anything
differently on brexit than Joe Swinson
so what were the mistakes you can't just
blame external factors oh but you're
asking to me for me to rush to early
judgment and I'm saying I'm not going to
you must have a sense after you you've
been out door locking you know you
you've you've been out you must have a
sense of what well let me give you let
me give me one example which I think
will be picked up in review I expect I
think we didn't get the other messages
over about what Liberal Democrats stand
for and we didn't get beyond the stock
brexit position so for example we've got
a very strong position on climate change
we we beef in fact Joe and I both said
during the general election that in many
ways tacking the climate emergency was
even bigger than stopping brexit but I'm
not sure if that very strong liberal
Democrat record and that strong set of
libel democrat polices and climate
change got through to enough voters and
I think one of the challenges we we fail
to manage is making sure that people
understood the little hats aren't just
the stock brexit party we've got many
other very attractive policies which
should have brought more people to to
vote to it what about the policy to
revoke article 52 cancel Breck say if
you won a majority was that a
distraction well I think I want to look
at the data on that because we did see
data where it was bringing people to
others as well as some data saying it
wasn't working and but because I
actually believe in evidence I believe
an evidence-based poll
it's why I don't think we should leave
the EU because the evidence is actually
but better off in the EU I want to see
the evidence before I read the evidence
is that you only 111 MPs isn't it it was
not a good night I'm not going to
pretend but there were glimmers of hope
let's remember that our vote share went
up we're now second in many more seats
than we were before the last election so
I think libel emma-crats can rebuild I
think we can come back strong and I
think if we focus on those very positive
messages defending human rights for
example we've got a government that's
been elected on a mandate to attack the
human rights legislation to actually go
after the the courts and reform the
courts attacking I think the
Independence of the judiciary on things
like judicial review we've got good
liberal value issues which we can
champion and I tell you one thing that's
going to happen very soon we're going to
see I hope and expect the report on
Russian interference in British
elections actually published I think
that would be very interesting and it
will be a Liberal Democrats who will be
holding Boris Johnson in person
to account for his links to Russian
business people what's the biggest
mistake of the election campaign backing
the election in the first place from the
Liberal Democrats it seems like it was
an act of political suicide and
registered now I think that's not
looking at what the dilemma was and
lemon was this we had tried time and
time again to get a people's vote to get
a referendum so that people have the
final say we had 17 attempts to that but
unfortunately the Labour Party didn't
show up in the numbers that were
required and therefore we then faced
with the Boris Johnson withdrawal bill
getting a majority with 19 Labour MPs
supporting it and there was a real fear
that that withdrawal agreement would get
through the House of Commons and so the
dilemma was this do we have an election
after Britain had legally been drawn
from the EU with ruderal Act or did we
have one before that was the choice and
you know we were faced with this I think
really meaningful meaning the slogan of
get brexit done but if we'd not had an
election we'd have had some sort of
other
meaningless solution slogan like let's
move on and so it was a real difficult
judgement to make and I think people
were moment are
not seeing what actually was ahead in
the face of the British Parliament at
the time there one of the people of
course he was paid perhaps the ultimate
price for that decision is Joseph winds
themselves she lost her seat do you feel
sorrowful absolutely the whole party is
a deeply upset and disappointed Joe was
a friend and a colleague and I want her
back in Parliament as soon as possible
she has so much to offer British
politics and you know our faults are
with her and her family but we know that
she has a bright future and we thank her
for what she did and I hope that we can
ensure that what she argued for and her
legacy on the prexy issue we can
continue because Liberal Democrats will
continue to approach brexit in
Parliament I'm sure he'll get his
legislation now the Drule agreement will
go through but now the hard part starts
for Boris Johnson could serve disc I do
not believe they can get brexit done in
the next year as they said they've done
they've told voters and leavers and
remains they'll get back see done next
year they won't and your words say about
Joseph Winston where perhaps not quite
knew it why everybody who watched those
results coming in we saw the video of
Nicola Sturgeon the leader of the SNP
celebrating the result when Joyce wins
then I lost I seek I look at the screen
I'm sure you've seen this what what's
your reaction she's not very dignified
as she and I think that approach to
politics are taking gleaned someone
else's defeat is in the way that she
does a very personal way isn't
appropriate for the First Minister fond
okay Devi thank you very much for being
on the program this morning